Naveed Rabbani: We should really get… I think we should get Lucy's…
Naveed Rabbani: I know we have to do more labeling work for her paper, but I really like that idea.
Naveed Rabbani: And this came up just yesterday, June.
Naveed Rabbani: Here, at Sutter, there was… someone put in the wrong weight, and it caused there to be a,
Naveed Rabbani: A dosing…
Naveed Rabbani: It affects the dosing, you know, and so then someone put in the wrong weight, they got the alert. So they got the alert, obviously. But if someone put in the wrong weight and didn't get the alert.
Naveed Rabbani: Because it was less than 10%, then that's another thing.
Naveed Rabbani: Right, so…
Joon Lee: So, it's a… it's a framing on actual…
Naveed Rabbani: It's a safety thing. Yeah.
Joon Lee: Residential.
Naveed Rabbani: Of course. Obviously, for… for,
Naveed Rabbani: for growth analysis, you need accurate data, but the weight dictates the dosage of medication that patients get. So that's another thing to keep in mind.
Zak Kohane: Yep, yep.
Naveed Rabbani: We saw this the other day, someone put in the wrong way to… the alert popped up, so that's not…
Naveed Rabbani: what we'd focus on, but we'd focus on the cases where the alert doesn't pop up, and if you don't have a very sensitive
Naveed Rabbani: alert, then you might… B.
Naveed Rabbani: missing things like that, so… I really think that one's a… that one's a good one, too.
Joon Lee: So… Similarly, how we did with Yannick, we…
Zak Kohane: Jeez.
Joon Lee: maybe…
Naveed Rabbani: And she basically is there… she's, like, 90% there, right? We just need to come to consensus. I think we never did this partly because I… the baby, you know, was born, and I was gone. I couldn't do it anymore, but…
Naveed Rabbani: What we needed, right, was we were each going to… Mark…
Naveed Rabbani: The errors, and then we were gonna come together and reconcile them.
Naveed Rabbani: I thought.
Naveed Rabbani: Is that what we were gonna do?
Zak Kohane: Which, wait, I'm sorry, which… what? Who? What? Tell me about that again?
Naveed Rabbani: I think we… I don't know that you were there for this one call. We had talked about assigning labeling tasks…
Naveed Rabbani: to the clinicians.
Naveed Rabbani: to go through…
Zak Kohane: I reshop's 10 cases.
Naveed Rabbani: For this is for Lucy's.
Zak Kohane: For who?
Naveed Rabbani: For Lucy's.
Joon Lee: is error detection.
Zak Kohane: Yeah, I'm sorry.
Naveed Rabbani: And then… and then we would come together.
Naveed Rabbani: Because there's… there wasn't a lot of concordance. Then we would come together and review the inconsistencies and come to consensus as a group, and then submit that as the final.
Naveed Rabbani: Ground truth. Dataset.
Joon Lee: Well…
Karl Santiago, MD: So, my, my recollection, sorry, dude, my recollection is that it was, it was,
Karl Santiago, MD: Like, some folks had done some of the labeling.
Karl Santiago, MD: And then, yeah, there was that… that realization, oh, there's… there's a… there's a need to…
Karl Santiago, MD: there's a need to define what abnormal means, like, what's our threshold for abnormal? And then after that, it's kind of re… after that recalibration, then, folks did more labeling.
Karl Santiago, MD: Or relabeling as it, as it…
Karl Santiago, MD: stood, and, after that, I don't know that there was… there was a plan to… to re…
Naveed Rabbani: Yeah.
Karl Santiago, MD: Review or recalibrate, so yeah, and…
Karl Santiago, MD: I wonder if there was, that's a good question, because I too am like, oh, you know, how did that now compare to,
Karl Santiago, MD: To what things were like before.
Karl Santiago, MD: I don't, I don't, I don't remember hearing anything about that.
Joon Lee: So, the fundamental issue is…
Joon Lee: The easy, extreme ones are very easy. Like, you cannot be 20 centimeters tall at any age.
Joon Lee: It's… the… Smaller variations where, at some point, we cannot distinguish from biological variations from errors.
Zak Kohane: That's right.
Joon Lee: How sensitive we are in this, like, what threshold we use on our labeling.
Joon Lee: Basically impacts the performance on any model where it's tuned at different different levels, so… It…
Zak Kohane: Yeah, so I think that, for that reason, We have to,
Zak Kohane: I think we have to actually make that point.
Zak Kohane: In the evaluation, and therefore make that part of the evaluation less central.
Zak Kohane: So, babe…
Joon Lee: That's a… point, plus… come up with…
Joon Lee: Reasonable way to evaluate different models, or our owns, and then show that, hey, this is doing better in this metric.
Zak Kohane: So, I think that we could have… what I'll do is… I'd have two metrics.
Zak Kohane: One is…
Zak Kohane: Outliers that are humans, think are…
Zak Kohane: Definitely abnormal.
Zak Kohane: And outliers where our… Bye.
Zak Kohane: And the subset of near misses were our experts.
Zak Kohane: Don't think.
Zak Kohane: That it's distinguishable for… from, from normal.
Zak Kohane: And so, therefore, we can get two performance metrics.
Zak Kohane: One is… Group 1, so there's two groups, outliers and
Zak Kohane: they're outliers, but it can't be distinguished. So, one is you could do a performance on the whole.
Zak Kohane: And on the whole, some of the other ones will actually slightly outperform, our algorithm.
Zak Kohane: But then, if you include Because there are vagaries biological variances.
Zak Kohane: in the growth curves. They're not perfect, simple, Curves.
Zak Kohane: it will show that ours has a lower false positive rate on those.
Joon Lee: How can you say it's… False positive, when we don't know whether it's…
Zak Kohane: Well, it's…
Joon Lee: outlier, or…
Zak Kohane: What we're saying is… Okay, what we're very much saying is.
Zak Kohane: If this was a real patient.
Zak Kohane: I would not do anything for that variation.
Zak Kohane: That's what our experts are telling us.
Zak Kohane: And… whether…
Joon Lee: The reason is because we cannot distinguish from biological variants from outliers. So, we don't… as a clinician, we don't have enough information to say something, hence we'll not do anything.
Zak Kohane: That's right.
Zak Kohane: And so.
Zak Kohane: And so we have now two sets, two denominators. One denominator is all outliers from a perfect curve.
Zak Kohane: And then the other is… Outliers that are… that… any clinical decision.
Zak Kohane: Or alertness would happen.
Joon Lee: So, actually… Maybe this is the definition of actual outlier…
Naveed Rabbani: Yeah.
Joon Lee: that Carl initially wanted, like.
Zak Kohane: Yes.
Joon Lee: It's only outlier when clinicians have… think that they have enough information to take certain action. If it's not, then we don't know whether it's biological deviation or… or…
Zak Kohane: Exactly.
Joon Lee: I cut it.
Joon Lee: Entry or data measurement error.
Zak Kohane: This comes out to low… low stakes, actionability.
Zak Kohane: In other words, even if the stake is as low as, hmm.
Zak Kohane: should I be worried about this patient? That's already actionable.
Zak Kohane: But if… It falls short of that very low threshold for actionability.
Zak Kohane: You know, Again, that no reasonable pediatrician would say.
Zak Kohane: what's going on with this kid? Should I… Should I be worried?
Zak Kohane: Leon.
Zak Kohane: And I think… I think I know that the ones that I did not include
Zak Kohane: meet that criteria. Like, there's no way I could tell myself, this is…
Zak Kohane: This is something I should worry about.
Joon Lee: Would clinicians…
Naveed Rabbani: But we're looking at these retrospectives.
Joon Lee: interpretation be?
Zak Kohane: And it's retrospective, so it's even better.
Zak Kohane: Because we know, after the fact, That nothing bad happened.
Naveed Rabbani: I think that's going to be…
Naveed Rabbani: I think that's going to be 2…
Naveed Rabbani: what's the right word? I don't think we'll get enough samples that way. We won't get enough…
Naveed Rabbani: That bar is too high.
Naveed Rabbani: I think we'll rarely look at the growth chart and be worried about… retrospectively be worried about these smaller variations that are less than 10%.
Naveed Rabbani: A deviation from the prior.
Zak Kohane: That's true.
Naveed Rabbani: measurement, in which case we won't do any better than the epic.
Naveed Rabbani: 10% rule.
Zak Kohane: Well, actually, I don't know if that's true. 10%.
Zak Kohane: I think that…
Zak Kohane: Well, I understand the problem about the fact that it's retrospective.
Zak Kohane: And so the real test would be
Zak Kohane: we want her, I think, to be helpful, is to show To redo the app.
Zak Kohane: So that it just shows one point in time, and you say, okay, okay, okay, not okay.
Joon Lee: So…
Zak Kohane: And, in fairness, it would get… very complicated.
Zak Kohane: So, let's say we're doing that, and a lot of these things
Zak Kohane: I see those flip-ups, so I say, not okay.
Zak Kohane: So that's an outlier.
Zak Kohane: And then it comes back.
Zak Kohane: Because it was a measurement error.
Zak Kohane: As I say, okay.
Zak Kohane: And then it goes back up, so I'll say, oh, maybe that one that went up.
Zak Kohane: Was.
Naveed Rabbani: Well…
Zak Kohane: Part of the…
Zak Kohane: the thing. And so, I think we don't want to play mind games like that on our, on our poor raters.
Zak Kohane: I think that we… you take just… you take slices.
Zak Kohane: Of this thing with only one perturbation.
Zak Kohane: And… show them up to it. Otherwise, Although it's legitimate, the…
Zak Kohane: combinatorics of the number of possible things that could happen is to become so large that we're only going to sample a small subspace of it.
Zak Kohane: You know.
Zak Kohane: Abnormal, gets close back to normal. Whoa, it goes back to abnormal. I can imagine a line that's going through the abnormal, and, you know.
Zak Kohane: So, I think that's just too complicated for most of our…
Zak Kohane: So I think what you do is you do a… take a slice, Where the points…
Zak Kohane: The points are stable.
Zak Kohane: Are on the line until that point.
Zak Kohane: And then we show the next… next one.
Zak Kohane: And it could be as few as 2 points.
Joon Lee: Or… shouldn't… human be presented the same…
Joon Lee: Amount of information, or same window size as the algorithm will be.
Joon Lee: using? Because always, When you saw… Only two measurements.
Zak Kohane: Yeah, I see your reset.
Joon Lee: Yeah, it can go up, but once you see the third one, suddenly you have more information about.
Zak Kohane: Yeah.
Joon Lee: you.
Zak Kohane: That's a good point, that's good.
Joon Lee: So…
Zak Kohane: Okay, so that's… okay, that sounds complicated, so let me try to back off with what we already have.
Zak Kohane: So… Because we can see the whole thing.
Zak Kohane: We… we have a God-like view, of… what happened?
Zak Kohane: So… I think what we're saying is… from the godlike view, We still think… Knowing what happened.
Zak Kohane: to a godlike view, we… at this…
Zak Kohane: We say this point is discounted.
Zak Kohane: And this point, is so close.
Zak Kohane: to normal variation, That we do not believe a clinician.
Zak Kohane: Would… should be.
Zak Kohane: Purturbed by it.
Joon Lee: Hmm…
Joon Lee: So it's a mirror of… Like, what we need to decide is, is… labeling from God's view.
Joon Lee: OK to be used to… to…
Joon Lee: It's measured performance of this model.
Zak Kohane: Well, it… it's… What it is… Is a harsh view It's… it's certainly a more…
Zak Kohane: it's… it's… it says we don't actually have to compare it to humans, prospectively, because humans… that's unfair. The humans…
Zak Kohane: Don't get to see the whole thing.
Zak Kohane: in real time. So we're saying, this is…
Zak Kohane: So, this will just… so this will just tell us about retro… how to retrospectively fix the curves up to… up to today.
Zak Kohane: That's what it… I guess that's what it did.
Naveed Rabbani: That's the right path. I still think that…
Joon Lee: problem we want to solve. Why this?
Naveed Rabbani: I think that's what you ultimately want to know in both cases, is was it an error or not? And only time will tell if it was an error. So I think it's an unfair comparison, but it's ultimately the application that…
Naveed Rabbani: It's the ideal, right? It's the ideal application of this technology.
Zak Kohane: Yep.
Naveed Rabbani: Because I can do prospective.
Naveed Rabbani: Judgment.
Naveed Rabbani: If something were able to do it better than me.
Naveed Rabbani: the gold standard would be that it would do it as well as I could do it retrospectively, but it would do it prospectively.
Zak Kohane: Right, right.
Zak Kohane: That's right.
Naveed Rabbani: actually better than me.
Zak Kohane: That's… that's… that's essential framing. Let me see if I can say it, because if I say I can say it, then I buy it.
Zak Kohane: So… If the program can do as well as me.
Zak Kohane: with God's eye view, But it's doing it prospectively.
Zak Kohane: then it's doing it better than me.
Zak Kohane: Cause there's no way I can do that.
Naveed Rabbani: And that's why I think we need to label it with the whole…
Naveed Rabbani: We need to have the whole growth chart, and we need to.
Zak Kohane: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Naveed Rabbani: We have to come up with…
Naveed Rabbani: What it, you know, what we're labeling, a definition for that, and so…
Naveed Rabbani: I think that's just the piece, like…
Zak Kohane: That's good, that was very helpful. Thank you, Navid, very clarifying. Gave me a headache, and and I now have to leave, because… not because I have a headache, but because it's top of the hour.
Zak Kohane: Rashad.
Joon Lee: The goal is…
Zak Kohane: Reshab, you're approved.
Zak Kohane: Congrats, Chef. Session, you're not… Session, you're not approved because you didn't complete the paperwork.
Seshu Mallina: Yes, I'm gonna meet with June right after this meeting, and then as soon as June approves it, I will be sending it right over.
Zak Kohane: Alright.
Joon Lee: I'll summarize this.
Zak Kohane: discussion.
Joon Lee: And share something soon.
Naveed Rabbani: Thanks, June.
Joon Lee: on Lucy's.
Naveed Rabbani: Let's get, Yannick back in the mix here. I know he's got work, but we need to figure out his paper.
Joon Lee: Yep.
Naveed Rabbani: So, if there's another time that we can all meet to talk about it…
Naveed Rabbani: That'd be helpful.
Joon Lee: On the last point, so basically…
Joon Lee: We don't want something that will do a little bit better
Joon Lee: Or on par as the clinician
Joon Lee: on each time point, we want something that's closer to God's view, where, as if it had.
Naveed Rabbani: Yeah, I… so I think…
Joon Lee: Whole data set.
Naveed Rabbani: What we'd need to do is label
Naveed Rabbani: these charts with the view of all the data points for each patient. But what we need to come up with is a definition of what we want to label, right? Like, what level of deviation. And it's very subjective, as we…
Naveed Rabbani: figured out, so… What I think I should do…
Joon Lee: Even… even the… would you take any action or not?
Naveed Rabbani: Yeah, I think even that is subjective. It's subjective, but I also think that is actually not…
Naveed Rabbani: That's… that's too high of a threshold, because it's rare that I would take action on one data.
Naveed Rabbani: That is different than the previous one, even if it were pretty different.
Joon Lee: How about framing it as, do you have enough action to
Joon Lee: Take any action, or not take any action.
Naveed Rabbani: I… I… the way I would frame it is, look at this growth chart. Which of these data points do you think should have been remeasured, because they were, you know, because they were significantly off?
Joon Lee: Just remeasured.
Naveed Rabbani: That's how I would think about it. Like, which one of these do you think is a significant enough deviation that you would re-measure it? In other words, it…
Naveed Rabbani: Is it enough of a deviation from the true value?
Naveed Rabbani: That isn't explained just from the noise and the measurement system? Because the measurement system is noisy, obviously.
Naveed Rabbani: That, you know, you would want to measure them again.
Joon Lee: So, this is…
Joon Lee: kind of, hey, we got this data, lots of data, of lots of patients, we want to use… we want to clean this up before we start the analysis, but do you think any of these should be actually sent back to the clinic and remeasured, so that we have
Joon Lee: That's… that's better than… that's, I think, quite concrete than…
Joon Lee: Would you take action or not?
Naveed Rabbani: Yeah, I think that's bet, and… and then we should have…
Naveed Rabbani: All the labelers, we should meet for, like, 30 minutes, and go, again, like we did last time, and go through one or two, so that we can all calibrate.
Naveed Rabbani: to what this means, because I think everyone will interpret it a little bit differently.
Naveed Rabbani: Then we can calibrate, and then we can go off and label on our own, and then reconvene and reconcile any
Naveed Rabbani: Any disagreements.
Joon Lee: Yeah, I like the last framing. Would you re-measure any of these? I think that's… I'll summarize this and share that, yeah.
Naveed Rabbani: But yeah, and then I gotta meet with Yannick, because we gotta figure out his paper. I think we should definitely submit it to PSB, and… you know, I want him to also see if he can make these new figures. I think they'd be really interesting.
Naveed Rabbani: I think that'd be a good addition.
Naveed Rabbani: We could get him working in,
Naveed Rabbani: And… I think we need to get him in.
Naveed Rabbani: to, google Docs.
Naveed Rabbani: Instead of OpenLeaf.
Naveed Rabbani: It's too difficult.
Joon Lee: Yeah…
Naveed Rabbani: this.
Joon Lee: Yeah.
Joon Lee: I'll… I'll send him a message after this.
Naveed Rabbani: I can make… I can make the Google document, actually.
Naveed Rabbani: You know.
Naveed Rabbani: Maybe… maybe that would help, if I make the Google document.
Naveed Rabbani: So I have a really nice reference manager, Google Docs.
Naveed Rabbani: That.
Joon Lee: Which one are you using?
Naveed Rabbani: Paper pile?
Joon Lee: Paper file, huh?
Naveed Rabbani: It's available at no additional cost from Harvard. Harvard has this, site license.
Naveed Rabbani: I really like it, it integrates really well in Google Docs, it's really easy to use. The only downside is you have to use the Chrome browser.
Naveed Rabbani: Which… so I have Chrome just for that.
Naveed Rabbani: I normally use Firefox, but
Naveed Rabbani: I keep a chrome… I keep Chrome around just for paper pile, just for writing papers.
Joon Lee: Okay.
Naveed Rabbani: cave.
Naveed Rabbani: team.
Joon Lee: I think we made some progress today.
Naveed Rabbani: Yes.
Naveed Rabbani: I'm gonna miss you all when you leave.
Naveed Rabbani: Rashad, says you.
Naveed Rabbani: It's been good.
Joon Lee: Yeah, maybe we should do a,
Joon Lee: some small trial with parents using Reshop's platform on gross.
Naveed Rabbani: Hmm… That'd be really interesting.
Joon Lee: She has an app or her thumb.
Naveed Rabbani: Yeah, to get the patient feedback would be really interesting.
Joon Lee: Yeah.
Naveed Rabbani: that's out of scope for a PPOC, but…
Naveed Rabbani: HMS, you could get another HMS IRB. PPOC is not allowed to do Research on its patients.
Joon Lee: As an entity.
Naveed Rabbani: It, it doesn't as well.
Joon Lee: Patients… like, parents have…
Joon Lee: Like, very strong incentives to re-measure if we say, this is… and then enter their… their height, so that we have…
Joon Lee: patient's parental height for everybody, like, they have…
Naveed Rabbani: You could do…
Joon Lee: Much higher incentives, yeah, yeah.
Naveed Rabbani: I think that…
Naveed Rabbani: That's really interesting. So, I… for Reshab's paper, we either get more doctors and more cases, or we add the patient perspective.
Naveed Rabbani: That's usually very difficult to do. Not a lot of papers have the patient perspective, because it's hard to get…
Naveed Rabbani: to patients. So that could be another way to bolster it to make it
Naveed Rabbani: Acceptable for one of these journals.
Naveed Rabbani: But let's see what Zach cooks up reshop. I think if… with the current number of…
Naveed Rabbani: cases and the number of physician reviewers. I would personally Target a conference.
Naveed Rabbani: But we'll see what… we'll see what he says.
Naveed Rabbani: Alright. Have a good weekend, everyone.
Joon Lee: Have a good weekend, see you!